سنذهب الى لبنان حيث بات حاكم مصرف لبنان
المركزي رياض سلامه مطلوبا للعداله القرار
اصبح ساري المفعول باصدار القاضيه
الفرنسيه المكلفه بالتحقيق في امواله
وممتلكاته في اوروبا مذكره توقيف دوليه
بحقه
ويشتبه المحققون الفرنسيون في ان السلامه
كما اصولا عقاريه ومصرفيه عبر عمليات
احتياليه كما يعتبر القضاء الفرنسي ان
سلامه استخدام اموال عامه لبنانيه خلال
توليه اداره مصرف لبنان طوال ثلاثه عقود
رياض سلامه الذي تغيب عن جلسه استجواب
كانت مقرره في باريس لم يتاخر في الدفاع
عن نفسه وقال ان اصدار مذكره توقيف دوليه
في حقه خرق لابسط القوانين مضيفا انه
سيطعن في هذا القرار
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات